bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce n'est pas le moment tout
simplement de mener une campagne
électorale selon vous non nous sommes
mobilisés dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire nous sommes dans l'urgence
comme au premier jour de cette de cette
crise depuis deux mois de mars et puis
dans le grand test nous avons connu la
coved peut être un peu plus que les
autres et nous avons mal vécu les
élections municipales avec toutes les
conséquences qui vont avec
ce n'est pas le moment où ce n'est pas
possible de mener convenablement une
campagne électorale dans un tel contexte
c'est à la fois pas le moment parce qu
on nous sollicite énormément sur le plan
de relance sur cette cette crise si on
est encore dans l'urgence on est dans
l'action et aujourd'hui c'est un peu
déplacé de d'entrer en campagne
électorale
d'autant plus que on n'a pas la
possibilité non plus d'aller à la
rencontre des habitants
donc c'est facile pour nous les
présidents nous sommes sept présidents
sortants on aurait pu bien sûr ne pas
demandé ce report des élections
on est peut-être un peu plus connus on
connaît nos politiques on est plus
visible mais on a en a estimé que les
élections ne seraient pas au rendez vous
pour tout le monde pour nous mais aussi
pour pour ceux qui seront qui seront
contre nous alors vous ne demandez pas
l'annulation de ces élections
départementales mais un report de trois
mois dans un contexte si imprévisible
qu'est ce que ça changera est ce que ça
changerait vraiment la donne ça change
simplement qu'on peut se mobiliser
encore pendant trois mois et trois mois
de cette fin d'année où on a vraiment
besoin de monter au front sur toutes nos
politiques et je le redis on est
fortement mobilisée par le plan du plan
de relance voulu par le par le
gouvernement et puis c'est vrai que on
peut on peut espérer que la situation
sera meilleure en juin mais le plus fait
en tout cas meilleur en juin quand
encore qu'en mars et on veut vraiment
avoir aussi du temps pour débattre pour
aller à la rencontre des habitants
trois mois c'est vrai vous avez raison
on ne connaît pas la situation du mois
de juin
qu'on n'ait pas la situation du mois de
mars c'est un petit répit petit répit
pour aussi nous mobiliser encore plus
dans l'est dans les semaines et les mois
à venir et vous administrez sur le
terrain qu'est ce qu'ils vous disent
justement pour l'instant vous savez une
on ne parle pas de d'élections parle pas
de politique
on est on est dans l'action et dans le
soutien on est dans les difficultés qui
viennent
on est là aussi pour les rassurer on est
là pour que l'économie ne s'écroule pas
on est là aussi pour les accompagner
parce que les départements ce sont les
collectivités des solidarités
aujourd'hui on a le nombre de
d'allocataires du rsa qui explose on a
de vraies inquiétudes dans nos ehpad
dans toutes nos tous nos services
d'accompagnement des aides des aides à
domicile voyez on est on est pas dans
une dans une période électorale alors
que finalement à six mois due à moins de
six mois du mois de mars en réalité on
est déjà dans une campagne préélectorale
vocaux demande au gouvernement d'agir
vite de prendre une décision pour nous
laisser agir sur nos territoires plutôt
que d'entrer en campagne
vous savez quand vous êtes en période de
campagne vous êtes aussi limité dans vos
actions et on voudrait vraiment pouvoir
agir en toute liberté
alors on vous aujourd'hui vous êtes sept
présidents de département a demandé ce
report de trois mois qu'est ce que cela
veut dire pour tous les autres que
finalement ils s'accommodent de cette
situation sanitaire
non ça veut simplement dire que c'est
cette président souhaitait remettre sur
la table la question des échéances
électorales du calendrier électoral
c'est le moment d'en parler je crois que
on a connu les hésitations des
municipales à quelques jours du premier
tour les annulée elle est reportée
on a en a vécu en tout cas le grand test
cette situation d'incertitude
je crois qu'il faut en parler librement
avec l'ensemble des présidents
département mais aussi avec les
présidents de région
on ne demande pas comme le gouvernement
le souhaitait un report des élections
un an ou 18 mois parce que c'était dans
les cartons le report des élections
départementales et régionales
après les élections présidentielles on
demande simplement un léger décalage qui
nous permettra d'agir dans les
prochaines semaines
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne nicolas lacroix
président du conseil départemental de la
haute marne